the idea that someone can quote unquote
hold their liquor it's been made
synonymous with masculine ideals it's
kind of crazy cuz we know it also it
crushes testosterone levels what's
interesting is that there's a very
different picture of a young drunk
versus an old drunk someone who's been
just drinking for too many years it's
not a pretty picture they they become
really infantile I'm not the
anti-alcohol Crusader I did that episode
not expecting much of a response
actually that CHS just how out of touch
sometimes I can be and I think it gave
people the excuse It's like the best
books tell you something that you
already know lots of people always had
an idea probably shouldn't be drinking
maybe I don't enjoy it that much maybe
these aren't my friends they're just my
drinking Partners maybe I don't like the
way that I feel the next day maybe my
life could be better if I stop drinking